I had a minor in theater in college and
we got into retail when I left school
and started in Pittsburgh and my first
job was actually mr. Rogers neighborhood
I was a scenic painter and then I was
the prop master for the Pittsburgh
Public Theater and in theater the prop
master is the set decorator so I was
very fortunate it was a very small
community and the main designer in
Pittsburgh at the time was the head of
drama at Carnegie Mellon so I was able
to learn while working basically it was
an apprenticeship I had some amazing
mentors there at the time and I started
in the paint department and worked my
way up as much as I could and did props
and realize that set decorating was
really what i needed to do and was
fortunate enough to be able to do it
there and then had an opportunity to
move to Los Angeles in the 80s and have
been going steadily ever since luckily I
think several of my peers have said the
spelled it out already that people think
we just shop and that we were interior
designers and I see it more as we r Co
storytellers that we help to convey what
the what the intention of the story is
would the intention of the film I think
it was Marvin March who said we have a
split second to let everyone know where
we are or what kind of person it is or
what they collect and that always has
stuck with me it's such a great
opportunity to present a slice of life
or a bit of a story that will go on
forever I mean we i watch movies from
the 30s and 40s so I think well maybe
someday someone will watch a movie that
I've helped with many years from now
what's become a lot faster i I'm of the
belief that we we collectively the
filmmakers have raised the expectations
of the audiences to such a level that
more and more as expected so a simple
line on the page and we go all the way
back the big joke is Atlanta burns but
it was a massive task and undertaking
but there are things being written these
days that are the same of you know equal
unrealistic proportions that it seems
the budgets of shrunk and the
expectations have grown and so I think
we're always that's always a struggle
and I'm sure that its age-old struggle
but it seems to have been a little more
constricting over the last few years
you